[موسيقى]
لديكم شهر واحد فقط لتنفذ اسلحتكم وهجومكم
محكوم بالفشل هكذا تقولها واشنطن صراحه في
وجه اوكرانيا ومصر تدخل خط الحرب
الاوكرانيه وتمد روسيا بالاسلحه والذخائر
فهل فعلها الفراعنه وامريكا لقد كشفنا
جاسوسا روسيا وهو من سرب الوثائق السريه
ومدينه اوكرانيه اخرى تبدا بالاستسلام
بشكل جماعي وتصريحات عسكريه من رئيسه
تايوان نحو الصين وبعد ان انهت بكين
تحرشاتها العسكريه الفلبين مع امريكا
تدشنان اول تحرك عسكري تجاه الصين فما
الذي يجري زعيم كوريا الشمالي يغلق سماعه
هاتفي في وجه امريكا وكوريا الجنوبيه
وايرلندا تنقذ حياه الرئيس الامريكي من
حادثه اغتيال وشيكا والسوريه تعود للاحضان
العربيه حرب التسريبات مشتعل صمد الاوكران
امام الضربات الخارجيه من الدب الروسي لكن
عندما تاتي الضربه من الاصدقاء والحلفاء
يكون اثرها بالغا على الجسد الاوكراني
لتاتي طعنه الغدر من الامريكان هذه المره
حيث لا تزال قضيه تسريب وثائق امريكيه
فائقه سريه تتفاعل في واشنطن والعديد من
عواصم الدول الخليفه وهنا تظهر وثيقه
مسربه جديده لتعلن ان الاستخبارات
الامريكيه تعلم ان الهجوم الاوكراني
المرتقب هذا الربيع لن يحقق اهدافه
الامريكيه حذرت مما سمته نواقص في حشد
القوات الاوكرانيه وامدادها وفقا
واما الضربه القويه للوثائق فكان حين تم
الكشف عن خساره كييف للدفاعاتها الجويه
بالكامل حيث سينفذ مخزونها من صواريخ باك
واس 3
بحلول مايو وفق التسريبات عن اي ضربه
نتحدث هل تهبط هذه التسريبات من معنويات
الاوكران لتعلن خسارتهم ولا تزال قضيه
التسريبات هي شغل
للامريكيين وحلفائهم حيث فجرت الصحيفه
الامريكيه قنبله من نوع اخر وذلك بان احدى
الوثائق المسربه ذكرت ان الرئيس المصري
امر بانتاج اربعين الف صاروخ ليتم شحنها
سرا الى روسيا اضافه الى خطط لتزويد روسيا
بقذائف المدفعيه والبارود بينما قال مسؤول
في الحكومه الامريكيه للصحيفه ان واشنطن
ليست على علم بتنفيذ خطه تزويد مصر لروسيا
بالصواريخ ولم ترى ذلك يحدث فهل يتجرا
الفراعنه ليكونوا اول دوله عربيه تعلن
دعمها العسكري للدب الروسي هنا جاءت
الاجابه من متحدث
بقوله ان الانباء حول خطط مزعومه مصر
لتزويد روسيا بالاف صواريخ سرا هي تلفيق
اخر لذا يجب التعامل مع مثل هذه التقارير
على هذا الاساس مضيفا انها علاقه مصر
وروسيا تشهد تعاونا كبيرا على اكثر من
صعيد على راسها الاقتصادي لكن لا يوجد اي
تعاون عسكري من هذا القبيل وفق قوله فكان
نفس اغني والله وعملوها الرجاله فهل ستترك
مصر فلسطين وتدعم روسيا برايكم هنا امريكا
تكتشف جاسوسا روسيا وليس بشريا بل
الالكتروني حيث تشير التحقيقات الامريكيه
الى ان التسريبات تمت عبر تطبيق ديسكورد
الخاصه بمجتمع العاب الفيديو لتعلن صحيفه
الدين ميل البريطانيه ان المحققين سينظرون
في الادله التي تظهر في هوامش الصور والتي
يمكن ان في كشف هويه المسرب بينما ينصب
التركيز في الولايات المتحده حاليا على ان
التسريب هو شان امريكي لكون كثير من
الوثائق كانت بايدي الامريكيين فقط بحسب
وكاله روترز انني اشتم رائحه خيانه وهذه
الخيانه في الداخل يا ابناء العم سام وها
هو جونكر هي المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي في البيت الابيض يصرح بان حجم ضرر
الوثائق المسربه على الامن القومي
الامريكي غير معروف المدى مضيفا ان واشنطن
ستواصل دعم اوكرانيا حتى بعد تسريب
الوثائق السريه ومن حرب المعلومات
والتسريبات الى اصداء اصوات القنابل
والمدافع حيث افادت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه بصدي قواتها 52 هجوما للقوات
الروسيه على محاور بخموت ولمان وابدي افكا
ومارينكا بمقاطعه
اوكرانيا مضيفه ان القصف الروسي ما زال
مستمرا على مقاطعتي خرسون والزبر جنوبي
البلاد في المقابل اكد الجيش الاوكراني ان
قوته قصفت مواقع للقوات الروسيه في ريفيزا
الجنوبي الحرب تستعر اكثر يا ساده ليؤكد
مؤسس قوات فاغمير الروسيه
الملقب بطباخ بوتين ان 80% من بخموت تخضع
لسيطره القوات الروسيه بينما اعلن ايغور
كيماجوفسكي مستشار القائم باعمال رئيس
الجمهوريه دونس في الروسيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه بدات بالاستسلام بشكل جماعي في
مدينه
لينتقل الروس الى مجلس الامن الدولي والذي
هو تحت سيطره روسيا لمده شهر حيث عقدت
جلسه دعت اليها روسيا لمناقشه المخاطر
الناجمه عن انتهاك الاتفاقيات المنظمه
لتصدير الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه وقال
المندوب الروسي الدائم لدى المجلس ان
الدول الغربيه تواصل الدعوه لمبدا التصرف
المسؤول اضافه الى الحد من نشر السلاحه
لكنها في الصراع الذي دفعت به في اوكرانيا
اثبتت عدم صدق تصريحات مسؤوليها على حد
تعبيرك المحيط الهادئ لا يهدا لا صوت يعلو
فوق صوت الاسلحه في بحر الصين الجنوبي
وضجيج المحركات الحربيه لا يتوقف لتندلع
التحرشات العسكريه نعم وبعد ان انهت بكين
تدريباتها هناك بدات الفلبين والولايات
المتحده
تحرشاتهما العسكريه باكبر مناورات عسكريه
مشتركه بينهما والتي تشمل لي اول مره
تدريبات بالذخيره الحيه وذلك لمواجهه
الاصرار الصيني المتزايد في المنطقه هذه
التدريبات سنو الدنيا اصدقاء وليست وليده
اللحظه لكن هذه المره يشارك فيها ضعف
القوات التي كانت فيها العام الماضي
بمشاركه ما يقرب من 18000 جندي فيما يطلق
عليها اسم بالاكيتان او كتفا بكتف الفلبين
فهل هناك من رد صيني وهنا لا يوقف اصحاب
العيون الضيقه تحركاتهم اساسا لتعلن وزاره
الدفاع التايوانيه انها رصدت ما لا يقل عن
تسع سفن حربيه وست وعشرين طائره مقاتله
صينيه في محيط الجزيره رغم انتهاء مناورات
الصين الضخمه التي اطلقت عليها السيف
المشترك مؤكده انبكين حشد الطائرات عسكريه
وعبرت خط الوسط من الشمال والوسط والجنوب
وكان بكين تابان تعود خاليه الوفاض فهل
تستعيد الصين جزيرتها رئيسه
لم تصمت وعبرت عن العالم بقولها ان
المناورات الصينيه ليست طريقه مسؤوله من
قبل دوله كبرى والجيش ومؤسسات الامن ستبقى
في حاله تاهب للدفاع عن البلاد رغم انتهاء
المناورات الصينيه وفق رويترز الاحداث
والتطورات
اعرب التاسيء عن اساسها الشديد ازاء رفض
كوريا الشماليه الرد على المكالمات
اليوميه عبر خط اتصال بين الكوريتين وخط
عسكري ساخن معتبره ان ذلك تحركا احادي
الجانب وغير مسؤول ما الذي تريده كوريا
الجنوبيه من كيم جونغ ولما كل تلك
الاتصالات قالت الشرطه في ايرلندا
الشماليه انها عثرت على اربع قنابل في
مقبره بالقرب منديري جاء ذلك قبل ساعات من
وصول الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى
الاراضي الايرلنديه فهل كان هنالك تحضير
لعمليه اغتيال
اكد نائب باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ضروره
الحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي الراهن للاماكن
المقدسه في القدس وحريه ممارسه العقيده
للجميع بينما خرج مؤيدون للقضيه
الفلسطينيه في تظاهرات بعده مدن غربيه في
كندا وامريكا وبريطانيا ممددين بانتهاكات
الاحتلال في المسجد الاقصى في شهر رمضان
المبارك اذا فماذا عن الدول المطبعه تبحث
الامانه العامه لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
امكانيه عوده سوريا الى جامعه الدول
العربيه خلال اجتماع يوم الجمعه المقبل في
مدينه جده بالسعوديه وافادت مصادر
الدبلوماسيه ان الاجتماع سيطرح امكانيه
مشاركه دمشق في القمه العربيه المقبله
الوثائق تغرق الامريكان اكثر وتلمح
الاقتراب نهايه المقاومه الاوكرانيه
برايكم هي وثائق سقطت بسبب اختراق
للاستخبارات الامريكيه ام انها طعم لاعداء
واشنطن
[موسيقى]